In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 31st, on which we commemorate the righteous
Elohimus, this blessed man lived during the reign of Emperor Theophilus, the iconoclast,
in the years 829 through 842.
His parents, Basil and Evdochia, from Cappadocia, were of Petrician rank.
They joined to the nobility of their rank, an unshakable faithfulness to the Orthodox faith,
and a fervent piety which they passed on to their Son.
Having received a refined education, Elohimus was given by the Emperor the charges of Candidatos,
Stratopedarch, that is military governor of Cappadocia and later of the whole empire.
But far from using these privileges for his own pleasure and glory, he made them the instruments
of virtue, and at the center of the world's tumult, he shone like a rose among thorns and
like gold in the furnace.
Nothing not only his chastity of the body, but also that of the mind, he never let his
gays rest on the face of a woman, and thus acquired the purity necessary to stand without
blemish before God.
To this chastity he added the abundant fruits of charity and mercy to the poor, the widows
and orphans, so that he became a truly chosen vessel of grace and a living icon of virtue.
Unsurpassable in love for his neighbor, he fled scandal like the plague, and not only took
care not to utter any sort of judgment of another, but also found the means of stopping others
saying anything that could hurt their neighbors.
He also taught that everyone must learn to listen rather than to speak, and he provided this
by putting all God's commandments into practice without much speech.
Falling gravely ill at the age of thirty, he, having made his preparations and taken leave
of those close to him, turned his prayer to God, asking that he should not be glorified
after his death.
Despite this pious hope, the lamp could not remain hidden under a bushel, and as soon as he
was laid in the tomb, just as he was with his clothes and footwear, a possessed man was
freed, and a paralyzed child got to its feet healed.
Miracles accrued round his tomb.
By means of the oil from the vigil lamp that burned there unceasingly, and also from a distance,
the earth from his grave that was sent to the sick, with which to rub their wounds and pains.
Fifteen months after his blessed entering into rest, Othochimos' grave was opened at his
mother's request, and his body was found to be completely incorrupt, giving off a marvelous fragrance.
These precious relics were translated to Constantinople and placed in the church of the mother of God
that had been built by the saint's parents.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.